sheldon plankton is the classic villain
from spongebob
who always miserably fails at stealing
the crowd patty secret formula
despite draining hundreds of thousands
of dollars if not millions into various
inventions and projects
plankton has not been able to get the
citizens of bikini bottom
to come this eating establishment given
his business failures
one would think that plankton is a broke
bomb like patrick
if he's not in millions of dollars of
debt already
but i'm here to tell you that plankton
is not just wealthy
but likely the richest resident in the
entire bikini bottom
and here's why
[Music]
well starting off we don't have to look
very far to realize plankton's absurd
personal wealth
just take a look at his wife plankton
has quite
literally made a robot wife which he
calls a wired
integrated female electroencephalograph
in other words
he created an artificially intelligent
robot over a decade before such
technology even became known to the
general public
one of the first mainstream advanced
robots was asimo
by honda which cost no less than 2.5
million dollars
and it should be noted that karen blows
asimo
out of the water as karen can generate
original thoughts
and even feel emotions like anger fear
and jealousy as a result karen
is no doubt worth tens of millions of
dollars of research and development
which plankton could easily sell to
various artificial intelligence
developers
like apple microsoft tesla and amazon
and that's not even taking into account
how early he was
onto the ai scene which would allow him
to sell karen
for hundreds of millions but that's just
the beginning
ai though quickly growing in relevance
is still mostly reserved for a very
niche audience
thus limiting its current profitability
the transportation industry however
is ginormous and will greatly appreciate
plankton's teleporter
now both plankton and sandy work
together on this to make this invention
a reality
so plankton should technically get 50 of
any revenue that is generated using the
machine
in 2019 the airline industry topped 800
billion
in revenue sandy and plankton don't have
to get directly involved in the business
of transporting people and packages
at all instead they can just license
their technology to companies like
delta emirates ups and fedex
they could essentially be the boeing or
airbus of the teleportation industry
even if they were only able to work out
a one person royalty
with 800 billion dollars in revenue
sandy and plankton would receive 8
billion annually
or 4 billion each and that's with the
current airline industry revenue
by creating a transportation solution
that is essentially instantaneous
we would likely see a large influx of
new travelers
as well as an increased frequency of
travel
on top of this they could no doubt
charge significantly more
for this improved mode of transportation
keeping all of this in mind
plankton and sandy could easily profit
tens of billions of dollars per year
just by licensing their teleportation
technology
next up we have plankton's fuel rods
these are just shown for a quick second
in the episode bottle burglars but this
is actually one of plankton's most
useful inventions
on the spent fuel rods box we are able
to see a skull
and on the cylindrical container right
next to it it warns of toxic waste
so it's safe to assume that these fuel
rods are some sort of nuclear energy
considering how many fuel rods plankton
has exhausted
it seems like he has gone these rods to
be a reliable and safe form of energy
though energy companies are often
ignored as they are usually
boring and uninspiring energy companies
are some of the most successful
companies in the world
in fact taking a look at the top
companies by revenue
in the world ranks two through seven go
to energy companies
in other words six of the top ten
companies by revenue
or energy companies nuclear energy is
often looked down upon
as it is often associated with nuclear
weapons and seen as dangerous
however over the past several decades
the safety
as well as the reliability of nuclear
energy has consistently increased
and though nuclear energy is not as
useful to everyday people
nuclear energy is especially useful for
space companies
who need their fuels to last years for
long missions
considering this with his fuel rods
plankton could likely score a
multi-billion dollar contract with
companies
like nasa and spacex as well as
governments around the world
moving on we have plankton's baby gas
this invention
is ingenious as it not only allows
people to stay young
but it also allows people to accomplish
this painlessly
the most prominent solution to fight
aging today is plastic surgery
aside from costing hundreds of thousands
of dollars per procedure
plastic surgery is often painful as
chemicals have been injected
and even surgeries have to be completed
however
with plankton's baby gas one doesn't
even have to get a shot to enjoy the
benefits
of this invention one simply has to waft
in some of these miracle fumes and
they're younger
thus the applications for this are
endless and would be highly sought after
of course we'll have a bunch of people
using it to stay young to party
but this would also allow us to preserve
the most valuable people of society
people like newton albert einstein
thomas edison
steve jobs and more recently elon musk
plankton's baby gas
would be the most valuable product in
history as the product itself is not
only genius
but it allows other geniuses to continue
inventing
and developing thus exponentially
increasing the value of the product
by now you're probably convinced of
plankton's immeasurable wealth
which could potentially even cross a
trillion dollar mark
but here's one more invention that
really captures the impact of plankton's
inventions
which is robot spongebob with this
invention
plankton was essentially able to conduct
a brain transplant to a robot
this would basically solve every
health-related issue
that has ever existed sure the baby gas
can make people younger
but it doesn't make people healthier and
wouldn't reverse disabilities
however robot spongebob could enable
paralyzed people to walk blind people to
see
and deaf people to hear as the only
organ required for functionality
is the brain and given the artificial
intelligence plankton was able to
develop with a karen
i'm sure he could also figure out a way
to fuse the artificial intelligence
with robot spongebob thus also helping
people with mental disabilities
evidently plankton's inventions have the
ability to revolutionize
entire industries such as the industries
of artificial intelligence
transportation and medicine and that's
not even taking into account his more
maniacal inventions
like his mind controlling buckets and
mind-controlling shampoo
which i'm sure several countries would
love to exploit
as a result metro crabs millions or
whatever
squandered next to plankton's billions
really
the only resident in the bikini bottom
who could even come close to rivaling
plankton's world
would be sandy cheeks however despite
his vast wealth
it's clear that plankton is quite
miserable as he is constantly defeated
while pursuing his passion
of owning a well-known local restaurant
so
for him money definitely did not make
him happy
however i feel like there is a very
simple solution for this
plankton could just serve as something
else as i'm sure
people would like to change from crabby
patties at least once in a while
but that's just what i think if you guys
like the depth of this analysis then
make sure to drop a like
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one
you